sharrow 86 willkommen zu einem neuen
video leute mich hat es jetzt auch
erwischt ihr habt vielleicht vor einigen
tagen das video von nutzern gesehen
darüber dass die weiße zähne gezogen
wurden und schatten meine ziele das
video auch mitverfolgen dachten sich bei
dieser mega geil wir wollen auch gerne
gezogen werden lassen ein bisschen ärger
machen damit er uns ziehen mussten kein
scheiß ungelogen vor drei tagen so ein
zwei tage nach lukas video hat mein
unteren linker weisheitszahn hier unten
angefangen mega ärger zu machen und er
ist nur eine sache ziehen
ja das ist das was heute passiert ich
habe in genau einer stunde bei einem
termin und weil so eine weiche zahn-op
eine sache ist die mega vielen leuten
begegnet immer ihres lebens ist glaube
ich ganz gut klar dokumentieren da ich
mal so berichtet wie die sache für mich
läuft ich werde natürlich eine lokale
betäubung kommen das heißt eine spritze
rein bekommen aber ich hab gesagt dass
wir zu wenig deswegen bekomme ich auch
noch lachgas um mich zu beruhigen und
natürlich ein bisschen umgeguckt das
lachgas mit den leuten macht und ich
muss sagen das beruhigt die leute
wirklich super da kann ja eigentlich
nichts schief gehen
doch folgendermaßen ich bin jetzt bei
andrea andré wird mich meinem auto zum
zahnarzt fahren und einen tag her wenn
ich vollkommen drogen bin fällt anderen
mich danach wieder mit meinem auto nach
hause zurück sodass ich autofahren
[Musik]
letzte mal dass heute auto fahre weil
der nach ewiger cd okay geht mal auf
youtube lachgas wirkung ein und zieht
die videos von 100 ich frage mich
ernsthaft ob das schon mal gemacht haben
so wird nutzte auflegen und 43
notwehr
ja das war ich habe jetzt eine baustelle
hier haben wir den schalter ist so gut
dass an der besten szene die es gibt
befindet sich ja
traust du bezahlst ausleger reagiert
nicht darauf machen wir doch erst drauf
und wenn du nicht auf der hier ist man
basiert dann locken
eine stunde dauert der vorgang jetzt
klingt so langsam die mit
fahrbereitschaft dort das heißt ich habe
mir natürlich dass meister einklagen und
auch die ärzte antibiotika und tabletten
[Musik]
das ist hat die hürde genommen ernster
genommen und ja ich fange dann tür und
der überhaupt die halter und hund film
über meine zeit hatte ich habe meine
tante wie ein spaß und das ist mein
versuch eine packung nudeln zu machen
ist einfach notwendigkeiten und meinte
ich dachte schon erste lasten like in
den kommentaren
ich habe heute von circa vier mal diese
worte die des rindes gewechselt wo man
sieht vielleicht auch schon hier ist
sondern leichte delle in meinem konto
nicht mehr aus aber man sieht hier jetzt
in nächsten morgen weißt du die dümmsten
verbrecher zeiten ich schnell den topf
auf diesen klassen darum und nach unten
das letzte was ich nicht mehr viel ist
dass ich die platte hier an gemacht habe
und der kontakt hier steht auf einer
unbeheizten platte der griff so rüber
dann reitet man hat dann geht zu hinweg
unter dem was rein tun fasst den angriff
bahn und der griff war teil von derweil
dass sie nicht mehr als dass die heiße
platte in der grip fragt über die
bereits heute drüber ich fast nur in
grip vorhanden und verbrennen die so
krass lasst uns doch das ist nicht das
was man noch mal sagen was wir brauchen
übrigens schmerzen entziehen habe ich
keine deswegen eigentlich muss ich kein
schmerzmittel nehmen jetzt habe ich mir
jetzt in der hand
ich will die welt gegangen jetzt muss
ich wieder so als würden ein paar tage
später habe ich jetzt fertiggemacht ich
gehe gleich in die uni hat von 13.30 bis
19 euro nie danach fahre ich nach
viereinhalb bis fünf stunden und ich
sehe wieder halbwegs zivilisierte aus
aber man merkt ist eine leichte beute
dann aber soweit schmerz fall dass
karsai eine verbrannte hunt formulierte
gutmann abendessen heute abend war
einfach fucking apfelmus und
schattenmorellen wie groß ist das und
guckt auf die bank
[Musik]
kein tempel drei die weiße zahn op war
vor zwei tagen kommen wie es aussieht
eigentlich so weit ganz okay ich habe
heute zum mittag erst mal wieder was
richtiges richtiges gegessen
ok gestern abend auf den weg nach köln
alles was gegessen
manchmal ist man ein kleines arschloch
in seinem leben auf jeden fall heute
mittag spaghetti mit garnelen gegessen
so weit alles gut es geht
ja leute heute ist der 23 am 19 hatte
ich meine operation das heißt jetzt der
vierte tag nach der op
so oder so leute ihr seht schon an der
backe da ist endlich überhaupt keine
stellung mehr da ist alles mehr gut
abgeklungen das war für mich hast du
gard auf das fucking bildschirm bist du
scheiße alter die kamera einfach gratis
bilder hätten scharf gestellt auf dass
hier die ganze sache lieber nicht gucken
muss ich sagen ich hab sogar nur am
morgen nach der op also am tag nach der
op noch schmerzmittel genommen am abend
nach der op glaube ich gar nicht mehr
hat danach keine schmerzen mehr gehabt
kann schnell zu die gebrauchtteile war
auf jeden fall mega easy aber was auf
jeden fall ist diese krasse einschränken
beimessen so man kann eigentlich nichts
mehr essen kein kaffee und ich trinke
richtig gern kaffee keine milchprodukte
nicht stärker umbauen muss nichts mit
körnern keine rohen früchte kein rohr
salat bittet mir auf meiner watchlist
mal live auf jeden fall taste mich
gerade so langsam wieder eine normale
ernährung heran
das heißt ich habe heute zum beispiel
mal nudeln mit sahnesoße gegessen und
auch mal gestern ein stück kürzer und so
was man eigentlich nicht machen sollen
weil milchprodukt aber mir geht's gut
soweit ich merke auf jeden fall dass die
op nicht so lange her ist er jetzt etwas
esse auf jemand schnell herum kommen
muss das geht nicht das muss man
wirklich aufpassen
deswegen sollten wir hier auch so eine
op habt haltet euch auf jeden fall
zumindest zu einem absoluten großteil an
die vorschriften wir haben einen
gewissen sinn ja das haus von diesem
video das ist immer so ein bisschen
vergleich könnt wie lukas weis tropez
und meine abliefen und mich auch so ein
bisschen die angst vor der ganzen sache
zu nehmen ich habe ja auf jeden fall
deutlich mehr angst gemacht als mehr
hätte machen sollen in diesem sinne
leute halt die ohren steif und die weiße
zähne aus dem scheiß drauf